you know you know what uh non-toxic game
i introduced these gamers to today uh
wordle oh yeah
i finally oh my god dude it was like a
weight lifted off my shoulders because
for for months now every time i go onto
twitter like five people on my timeline
are just like tweeting out these like
like these [ __ ] squares it's like
these yellow and green squares i'm just
like is he are this is this like
hieroglyphs or something like what's
what's going on i was like is this like
an invitation to a cult or something
like do i have to decipher this and then
i joined like the [ __ ]
the stone smiths or whatever the [ __ ] is
going on
i was almost more confused once gant had
actually explained it to me because i
was like why are people tweeting this
out
admittedly it's good it's like a good
like little time waster because there's
only one word a day right yeah yeah i i
think it's like their their marketing
strat i don't know it feels like on
purpose but it was like [ __ ] five hit
right because everyone gets the same
word every day and you only get one
words a day right and when you tweet it
out it's kind of like i don't know it's
kind of like tweeting out like a gold
star or something or like an achievement
in a video game right but it's the
equivalent of being like yeah so uh
yesterday i beat level 127 of candy
crush in like two minutes yeah i mean i
don't know my level i i don't i don't
tweet it out i just do it just to prove
to all the tweets that i see that i can
do it every day yeah i sat there and i
was like but why why would anyone tweet
this out
because like because i guessed a
five-letter word correctly
because i was right
i just couldn't understand it my am i
missing something
like is it no what about it is an
achievement i'm not attacking anyone who
has tweeted out you can do it in the
[ __ ]
i just there's some people who were like
they were like i don't know pretty like
big accounts i'm like why the [ __ ] you
tweeting about wordle yeah i'd like i
had like two or three people i followed
that i think we're like actively
at one point we're like what the [ __ ] is
this world [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] know and
then like a week later they're like
got it in two tries baby i was like oh
no
is this final fantasy 14 all over again
no because like the thing i don't
understand about how this trend started
is like
what made people want to tweet in the
first place right because who sits there
and it's like yeah i gotta let everyone
[ __ ] get like
you know when you like have an app open
and you get like that notification which
is like would you like to review this
app and then post it on your timeline
share your results like who's yeah share
your results who's ever [ __ ] shared
the results before wordle existed and
what what was the black magic the word
will put on their users to make people
want to share the results like when i
get like a high school and temple run
i'm not [ __ ] sharing that because
because it's a [ __ ] mobile share it
to your facebook friends it's like no i
don't think i will yeah everyone is like
yo facebook sucks like you know twitter
is slowly becoming facebook this is what
boomers do this is what they do yeah
they're like look what i got in
farmville it's like what we're no better
than them
but like what i think it's it's like the
equivalent of like having a newspaper
with like uh like the crossword yeah
right yeah and like your grandpa comes
and shows you oh look at this completely
crosstalks are too hard yeah yeah
way harder yeah it went it went from
crosswords to like newspaper sudoku
puzzles and then it's now wordle
because i thought because i was what i
was surprised the most about wordle was
that i thought it was like an app
yeah yeah like all those other ones
right but then i realized it's the
[ __ ] new york times yeah it's just
this is like a thing that the new york
times has just like i remember it's joey
searching for it on like the app store
like no you're just you're just typing
in the brand and i'm like why is there
like russian apps coming up on my thing
like this
that's when new york times bought it
yeah they bought it oh okay big brain
yeah i i remember i tweeted ages ago i
was like i don't know what world all is
and it's been so long that i was too
afraid to ask yeah at least well i mean
you weren't afraid to ask because you
tweeted it out i was actually afraid to
ask about i don't even wanna i'm keeping
this in the drafts bro i'm [ __ ]
talking i mean like i i like tried my
longest to like just not google it yeah
i like refuse to give it the attention
yeah yeah yeah this is gonna die in a
week
and then like i was just like it's going
to it's it's something that's going to
die in a [ __ ] week or something i
don't [ __ ] know i'll let twitter burn
itself out i didn't even know what it
was called so like i got this close to
like going onto google and being like uh
green and yellow squares on my twitter
timeline
yeah then yeah then i gave it a week
yeah didn't die give it two weeks and
people were still posting about it and
i'm just like okay
i need i just i'm just i'm just curious
just curious okay so how long have you
been doing well now for like for like a
good week or something just just just
every day you just log on when i
remember to when i remember normally
when i see it pop up my timeline i'm
like [ __ ] you that's the reminder [ __ ]
you look at this man right here
great now now our [ __ ] staff members
are getting into it
you're in three tries
how many tries did you get three oh okay
[ __ ]
it took me four
damn bigger brain all right take these
guys for helping each other dude thank
you they got a single letter for free
what he gave me a that's hard yeah he
gave me him
no i give you m in the right spot come
on
sorry he like didn't help
i'm just like these boys are cheating
this is this is this is an individual
game you know you know you're not
supposed to choose uh you should play uh
babble royale have you seen that game
scrabble battle royale oh yeah i've
heard of it yeah that one that was fun
i just really want i just really miss
playing scrabble
i've never played is that boomer of me
to say i've never played a game of
scratch you've never played scrabble no
dude like you like people keep saying
like oh yeah uno is a friendship bender
monopolist no scrabble is the real
french avenger you know you know your
friendship is [ __ ] when you're
fighting with a dictionary in your hand
like that's when you know your
friendship is in the dire strait right
it's like that's that's like oh yeah we
got a problem there are a lot of like
three and two letter words that you're
like this is a word yeah yeah yeah and
then when like you know and then the
argument always comes along with being
like well if it's like a commonly used
word that's not in the dictionary it's
allowed like am i allowed to use the
word yeet
because you know why is like a lot of
points it's not in the dictionary though
and then that's when the friendships
just crack we should do it on stream i
think i think vax and anti-vaxx is in
the uh in the dictionary now there's a
lot of people double x yeah likes that
it's a lot of points you can get on v
and an x
god damn
everyone's gonna be like scrambling for
those dnxes now man
are we doing a dictionary one or a
non-dictionary run because i thought
dictionaries weren't allowed in scrabble
you say it like it's a speed writer
it's like
a math thing calculator
[Laughter]
no we should we should definitely do a
scrabble uh game on uh on after dark
because that
honestly like it's it's
it's it's legitimately fun i'm not just
saying like i'm not being a boomer here
like it's legitimately fine you seem to
like word games though because remember
you you have countdown was just like yo
this game exists yo how have i never
right it's like yeah like countdown i
had a lot of fun in and you got me into
wordle
it's all word games dude
i don't know it's just something fun
about but then again like recently i
have been getting quite boomer yeah i
did see your video which is like am i
getting too old and i remember seeing
that and i'm just like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you what are you my comment sister
27 he's like i'm dying guys shut the
[ __ ] up
no no i'm like if you're old joey then
what am i see this is how you know these
boys didn't actually watch the video no
i i i did watch the video